[Music]
good news Bart tyka is going to grow up
with a reduced likelihood of conduct and
pure problem just Title II just like
what does that mean how come he's gonna
grow up with reduced the typical peer
problems because it appears in this
latest study that was published in
pediatric research it found that
children aged 2 to 5 years old who came
from dog owning households and they
regularly went on family dog walks or
they actively played with their dogs
every week had a reduced like we heard
of conduct and periodic problem what I
mean what's the show no we go on hikes
every week with dogs yeah but he doesn't
like play with her and then when he's
she's whenever I go to house she's
hiding in the other room from him she's
looking afraid of him well fawn also has
problems but when it was bigge intact
that they were but what was bring your
life with yeah well she was he would
play with her mm-hmm but fun fun is like
she she's like who's this creature this
is us he's like he's like a Tasmanian
devil is too much energy we are gonna
get another dog soon oh you are yeah and
like six months to you what okay so
they're saying that it will increase
pro-social behaviors such as sharing and
cooperating compared to children that
grow up in a household without a dog so
lots of doings well there you're only
focusing on dogs here okay so the
researchers surveyed 1646 parents to
determine whether families with
preschoolers owned a dog and how often
the child went on family dog walks or
actively played with their dog mm-hmm so
they found that 30 to 40 percent of dog
moaning household children were less
likely to have peer problems so like
sharing and stuff peer problem pure my
friend's daughter through a fire truck
at a at a schoolmate and she had a dog
she's that's wrong she had a superhuman
power just picked up a fire truck
she needs dr. Xavier and
she was dogged her I I grew up with dogs
too but they mainly stayed outside cuz
there are big dogs and my mom didn't
like dogs inside the house I think the
key element here is the fact that you're
playing with the dogs or you're involved
with the dog walks like somehow like
being responsible with and like that's
how you're able to learn like sharing
and stuff
pull the dog's ears and [ __ ] and then
she try to do that - my name's Jim Brown
and how [ __ ] does it take that [ __ ] it
was bitter
he was just like that's her fault the
dead yeah that's 20 so more the study it
says that they had 23% fewer total
difficulties and we're 34 percent more
likely to have pro-social behaviors
which I mentioned so yeah it just seems
like if you have a dog in your household
and you have a preschooler and they're
pretty involved with your dog they're
gonna have better social skills
I'd like to anti Kawakawa then him so
it's so funny like it looks like if any
time fallen takes off Tyga's done here's
gonna be dragon before but she's
actually like a really gentle Walker so
[ __ ] Ashley Walker you know she's
always like wearing hey you can you ride
her nice kind of week which is that Miss
Brown bad you do you ride meet love you
love Nami else is a little [ __ ] though
like every time I try to put tack on
Bridget would let you do anything she
was awesome because she wasn't even
there her brain is somewhere else
her brain's by a fish is here you just
pick the cutest but the worst dog I know
well it was like the universe brought
them together yeah they did have a happy
home with us pretty cool yeah but now
our next dog we're probably gonna buy
them so that because they're a puppy so
cuz I'm kind of scary if we rescue
another big dog and then they're not
that good with children they might build
up by Tiger so we want to get maybe two
puppies and raised the puppies
tanka so they're like you just fonts
paradise into ten ten or eleven damn Oh
cuz you guys got dog too as they were
older that's why I was like yeah that
makes sense
well we've also had fun for like eight
years now and to get her a shoo-in she
was four yeah
Robert like seven years now yeah what
Bond lived with us we had Fondren means
you were still living in Monterey Park
yeah you had fun by the time I came
around I was more than eight years ago
hopefully he'll just might be 35 fun was
there prior to me coming here how did
you call me - I never met patches oh you
guys are my patches huh
no never I've seen videos of patches
doing this yeah she stank so bad her
breath smells so bad I have had fun for
more than eight years yeah yeah at least
sick fawns pretty old yeah yeah a lot of
dogs yeah cuz I was in JK for six years
but Vaughn was already there part yeah
choosing the videos at least two or
three years before I came on whoa that's
been six years since mm-hmm kind of all
the dolls yeah this is the first time in
my life that I haven't had a dog for
like a while I know you have zero
animals in your life zero-g brno animals
do you feel do you feel sad or not um
cuz now you could travel wherever you
want without the responsibility I kind
of like the no responsibility like it's
yeah okay it's [ __ ] cool it's kind of
like having a kid that grew up and left
your house and if I want to like there's
dogs to pet and then play with and then
I couldn't look I actually watch videos
well yeah animal videos are like the
best yeah watch videos and I'm just like
ah dog and then I do kind of miss
certain things but then I think about
having to wake up take them out they
have to take a [ __ ] you gotta feed up
then there's this [ __ ] routine and
you're gonna go travel you got to find a
place to take and I'm just like yes man
that's the reason why I got cast you
still got to find somebody to feed the
cat if it's smaller than three days then
yeah but it was less than three days
thrown dry food chef yeah you know they
have to be on dry food yeah yeah yeah
cuz ours like they just get the
automatic feeder and I'm allergic to
catch too so I don't want to deal with
it okay
I'll be cool hey uh super high pollen
but they are I love your kitty hope
because she know oh it's two of them now
there's two two bagels and you get the
other one about a year ago
yeah he was born in man his name is
Morpheus mortgage yeah we got Tiger Lily
in Morpheus Shh
he'd gather both fixed oh they're both
bangles Morpheus no Tiger Lily or
something Oh like Peter Pan okay that's
right yeah
Tiger Lily and then Morpheus he got him
next
he's freaking crazy though they're like
night and day different she's like super
quiet superb like bleep light and like a
smart plays fetch and everything like
that well I was how to communicate very
clearly Morpheus don't even still know
his [ __ ] name they know they don't
give a [ __ ] is what I read no she she
does she knows every time she's like a
dog it's crazy
they look like really really smart but
he's just a troublemaker a good one that
is stupid oh it's sometimes he's either
really stupid or he's very smart
I don't know which one it is very smart
just give it really dumb or evil smart
you know to me in food art cat the guy
catfish it's everywhere he's [ __ ]
smart
like I know hope but he keeps taking
shits everywhere right no he's trying to
get onto the skin he's doing it on
purpose so the reason why he's doing it
on purpose is because and this is still
a theory we haven't we haven't concluded
to find out this is true because we
haven't done it yet but we think it's
because a kitty litter is - it's the
pellets and so the kitty
they have like super soft as paws so we
think all these years and he's been
[ __ ] everywhere just because he's
trying to tell us like we know I don't
like this [ __ ] kitty litter change
the kitty litter and so literally today
Casey's getting the new litter and we're
gonna see if it will change a lot yeah
he changed that it was like four years
and we haven't done anything like we're
just bad owners but I just keep getting
mad at the cat
had the one that when they pee on it
that Febreze comes out so it's a
moisture activated that's the crystals
I'm not too sure was a blue pellets
mm-hmm and then I say to myself yeah
yeah right when they peed on it and then
like they would move it around
yeah more than what I have the three
kids you still have no no I got them
adopted yeah they were the cutest and it
took care of themselves
now just because I'm a captain neurology
coming on my stomach and sleep they
don't [ __ ] anywhere that they want to
like they know they all went to the
cat's no yeah cats do they know that
that's the kitty litter like you don't
even train them like you set it up and
they just no no they want to be clean
always they want the glue themselves
like it's very lucky have they ever
marked in your house though no not on
purpose not on purpose
yeah like mom the model of Morpheus will
only do it when the litter is too stinky
so it's like and so now we had to learn
like two or three times it's pretty a
pile of clothes are on the bed or
something
but right before he does he'll always
try to tell us but like you know
sometimes your your cats just like meows
you don't even know but because if they
were speaking articulate they like the
litter is dirty please save me before I
pee all over this place right you know
what I'm saying that yeah what are you
saying holy oh I don't know what I think
I'd rather have the [ __ ] because P is
like wow it's
tapis from ten yeah the ammonia is big
uh-uh no I think I'd rather just drink
no water just how the body processes it
yeah is it or is it after you leave it
for a bit what it's not right away where
it smells right oh it smells right
really oh my Garret yeah so like the
litter wouldn't smell until like you say
you leave for a week and that's what I
like starts to like really stink that's
what I would smell but other than that I
am a week I have to clean out the litter
every night yeah every day you're out
there picking up the [ __ ] of your pet
you're the [ __ ] but not I mean same with
the dog yeah no that's what I'm saying
it's like who owns who like well
oh nice man yeah it is well to be fair
like it's still pretty clear that like
you can be a master of a dog but it's
very clear that you will never be the
master of a cat well if I if I own a pet
I want them to do stuff for me clean my
[ __ ] mm-hmm you know well I think Todd
one of our cats had a sit it was really
cute oh cool
yeah yeah I'd like some of the dry food
it was our cat sir
fat cats like they absolutely loved
their food and because it's on an
automatic feeder every time like right
before it's the time for them to get the
food ready they're like oh [ __ ] so he
was able to teach him how to sit in like
in like 10 minutes it was really fast
but we brought an automatic feeder at
home and Morpheus broke into it within
30 seconds they brought a stethoscope
yeah we just had no idea how to Amy just
eats all of it yeah ours he knows how to
stick his paw in there and like scoop up
the food yeah cats are smart we created
the the no food out rule because of
because of one of our cats Morpheus he
like literally like nope he'll just
freakin go for it you know it's like
super ik by your own comes around yeah
your own food just kinda runs these
feels your how do you prevent that
behave you got to keep a nerf gun right
next year let me hit over a bottle no we
can't do this well yeah we don't want to
do this spray room he steals from you
there is no respect mm-hmm but that's
the problem it's like like when when he
steals from you is to think wanna get
angry but then the second you start
getting angry at like a small cat it's
like it doesn't go anywhere you know you
don't want to enable that behavior
though right huh you don't you wouldn't
want to go or you you try to catch him
you get the food out there oh [ __ ]
smart though cuz like for example with
me if I'm around they wouldn't even dare
to step paw on the countertops it's like
[ __ ] no you're never gonna be on the
countertop that's where we prep our food
no cats on the countertops but then
Casey's they're doing like working on
his laptop he never tells him anything
so they're literally on the dining table
right next to like like pushing onto
there his
top and stuff like trying to get his
attention and then I come downstairs and
they immediately get off like they know
with mom you don't buck around in there
yeah it's just so funny so yeah like
they they know like which person has
which personality to feel like that lady
mean yeah lady will yell at me I missed
the cats
[Music]
[Music]